our friend kevin knuth and i'll read it
so he wants to know what is life it's a
question that people have entertained
for a long time without obvious answers
your thoughts on observers i sent them
your video on observers seem to be
relevant i have always thought of living
things as systems that use information
to create some kind of model of the
world around them in order to locate and
take advantage of potential energy
gradients which are then used to keep
them away from equilibrium and i can
give some examples and so on i would
agree that a hurricane is not alive a
hurricane's a heat engine that he's
referencing your talk however it's not
alive because it doesn't use the
information about its surrounding to
model these energy gradients the models
living things can employ are quite
diverse for humans these are our mental
models et cetera et cetera some bacteria
etc so these are my thoughts about life
i really need to write them down maybe
david would be interested in working
with me on this
okay so this these are kevin knuts
thoughts i'm sure you can pull a
question out from that or just comment
on it as a whole
um
yes so
um what kevin
what he's talking about here first of
all um hi kevin and yes i think we could
have some very interesting discussions
about here um
so as i mentioned before and um okay so
backing it up kevin is talking about
presentation i made that's where there
was observers and hurricanes and so on
um the observers are on what i was there
i'm using as a term to describe
these non-equilibrium steady states
that if you were to um basically in a
judah pearl sense intervene of the
information flow
from the outside world into these
systems
they would no longer be at
non-equilibrium they would actually
collapse to being at equilibrium
and we were calling that in this is what
we were calling an observer
this was um
what they were called in this talk of
mine that kevin saw
and um the and we were
making the definitions be
um we were careful
so that we would not i mean whereas
observer and alive are being just
mangled around here
but um that we were trying to make it so
that a hurricane is not in a certain
sense observing its environment
um whereas say a paramecium going up a
uh
gradient of
food is observing its environment and is
alive
so um
let's see so
well
i am my collaborator or artemy kochinsky
um we're going after in that paper
where we define semantic information and
observation
and so on as a non-equilibrium study is
a system that's in a non-equilibrium
steady state
such that if you intervened on the
information it gets from the outside
world
it would collapse to equilibrium
equilibrium being a synonym for depth
we were um saying that those are systems
that are either observers or living or
just generally of interest without using
loaded terminology
um that is all the what
kevin is talking about models that the
system has internally
that is that basically play a middle
step
in the map from the information entering
from the outside
to the actions that the
entity does back on the outside
that a lot that end up allowing the
entity to be away from equilibrium
the model is the way that it does that
it's a way of interpreting what's going
on in the entity in between these steps
of getting information from the outside
and then acting back on the outside
um
what we were
analyzing in our work
deleted that step we were not trying to
say anything about internal models we
were simply saying the end result is
that if you interrupt the information
flow from the outside
we were saying nothing about the reasons
whether it go through models or some
other
phenomena but the ultimate effect was
that you collapsed back to equilibrium
so it was saying that if you if i sunder
the information you're going from the
outside you're getting right now
information from the outside about where
a cheeseburger is on a table
if i stop that information flow
eventually you die you fall back to
equilibrium
so that's that so what you are doing is
you are right now in a non-equilibrium
steady state because you're getting
information from the outside world and
what i and what we were analyzing there
is systems
where if you were to chop that
information flow from the outside world
the result is that they actually
collapse back down into being
equilibrium they die
the means by which that happens
in your particular case are well if you
had that information about where the
cheeseburger is you could then reach out
your hand based upon an internal model
of the outside world grab that
cheeseburger bring it to your mouth
digest it
get a whole bunch of glucose which is
what you then use to stay out of
equilibrium
so that's everything that happened in
between
you're getting the information and
you're staying out of equilibrium
in other processes like the paramecium
it's getting information about the
gradient of a chemical in its
environment
it is then using that information one
could maybe say a plus a genetic model
that's what kevin is saying but whatever
the end result is that it uses that to
determine
how it should reorient itself before it
uses this flagella to actually move
so that it can actually then ingest on
these particular chemicals and that's
how it stays out of equilibrium
so in my work with artemy kalczynski all
that we did was looked at the
the beginning point and the end point
notice that you need the information
coming in to stay out of equilibrium
those are interesting systems we said
from a physics point of view
kevin is now discussing is a special
case of such systems
which are physics systems that capture
at least a large part of what is
what one might want to say is a living
system they're not just interesting
these things they do capture a large
part of what it means to be alive
so that's a very long-winded answer to
question to kevin's question kevin yes
um if you do want to in particular the
directed information flow of people like
daniel palani and niha i
i think could be a very very interesting
fruitful way to try to build more
structure
into these particular systems
a halfway point to building full-on
internal models
so yeah kevin drop me a line